B.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
August 29th,
2080 Oh happy baseball championship.
Pappy baseball championship.
Why am I in such a good mood?
Why do I want to walk down the street with a fucking bass drum kick in my
fucking feed up in the air?
Because your 2018 Boston red sox once again are world series champions.
Do you believe it?
Okay,
I think I speak for all the New England when I say fuck anyone.
Okay.
Unbelievable.
I remember after 2003 thinking all I want to do is just see these fucking
assholes.
Just one buck and time have a clutch fucking moment in your fucking life.
You Red Sox were in concert stats where I was at.
All right,
and the very next year they went in and I was like,
you know what?
That's it.
I,
you know,
I'm in such a good mood.
I don't give a fuck that my phone is making noise in the background.
That's what's over in a great mood.
I'm in all,
I wanted to see what you,
some when it once now only to get to see him when at once now I,
anyway,
I tried three times.
Four Times.
Okay.
The one buying the Patriots.
So all you haters out there,
just in case you lost count in this century,
we won five Superbowls,
four world series titles and Nba Championship and a Stanley Cup and one of those
soccer championships,
mls,
whatever.
They,
but when did championships and stuff,
I don't even give a fuck about.
All right.
And for all,
you guys don't,
and does it get old after a while?
Don't you get tired of it?
No.
Fucking awesome.
It's fucking awesome.
You know,
and you know,
if it doesn't happen to us,
I hope it happens to you someday unless you were in fucking New York or in
Montreal or a Laker Fan.
Other than that,
I,
I got no fucking problem with anybody.
Um,
unbelievable.
Uh,
I know what to say.
You know,
what's this?
We don't have as Jackie Bradley jr or JD Martinez,
one of them said after game three that I was at,
I can't believe I was at the game.
MMM.
He said,
I've never seen it take a team,
get just get punched in the face and then just get up like nothing happened.
Like this team,
something like that.
I know I'm butchering it,
but it was just perfect.
Okay.
Um,
they would just never out of it.
I have not seen a team score.
This many fucking runs with two outs be down this much since the 1998 New York
Yankees,
which is probably the best team I've ever seen.
MMM.
The only other team in my lifetime,
and I vaguely remember them,
was maybe the big red machine.
Um,
I mean that team,
that team was fucking incredible.
That was just another team that was just like,
they were just stacked.
All right.
You know what I'm going to,
I'm not,
I'm lying a little bit that,
that phone thing is going to bug me here.
This continues to happen here.
All right.
Uh,
oh fuck.
Am I supposed to talk about that shit too.
Um,
anyways,
um,
congratulations to the Dodgers,
man.
Jesus Christ.
See another great season.
You just came up short.
All I can tell you having been through that.
MMM,
yeah,
no,
it just makes it all the more sweeter when you finally when it,
but uh,
you know,
so we went to game theory.
What a fucking great stadium by the way.
And not always a great stadium that the Dodgers have like the stadium.
It's just considering when it was built and there was so many of those soldiers,
cookie cutter,
um,
baseball stadiums that they made.
They were multipurpose.
Basically all of them were to design so you could play football and baseball
back there.
A very like forward thinking,
money saving environmentally friendly thing that we did.
And then we all decided like,
you know what?
Fuck these stadiums.
They're old.
Why fix him up?
I don't understand why you just can't fix him up.
They're made out of metal and concrete.
They're not gone anywhere.
That's like,
yeah,
getting fucking car.
You have the fucking engine block is made out of steel.
As long as you take care of it,
it's gonna,
it's gonna run forever.
Everybody's just throw shit out.
So they knocked down all of these fucking stadiums and then rebuild.
Not at one,
but two more stadiums.
We where I want my own stadium.
I don't want to share,
although,
you know,
I did boomer Esiason show boomer in and it was it Gino and uh,
okay.
He was talking about what it was like to play for the Cincinnati,
Cincinnati Bangles in the same in riverfront stadium.
He said Dow these to cover a home plate with a piece of wood and then just
through astro turf on top of it.
So if you get tackled on that,
basically it's like you laid it on somebody's tree fort.
So I guess,
you know,
maybe that's the reason,
but I would,
what I thought they could've come up with some sort of technology where they
didn't have to fuck it.
That was just basically,
cause it was astro turf.
Right.
I don't know.
I don't pretend to understand,
but,
um,
me and my buddies,
we went to game three and,
uh,
I didn't wear any red sox.
Shit's still almost got into a fight.
Fucking west coast still almost got into a fight.
Unfucking believable,
you know,
there was like,
what killed me was we went to the game and there was so many empty seats because
stub hub just gouge the shit out of every,
they were charging like 700 bucks.
I was at the top of the state and those tickets were over $700.
And you know,
I guess stubhub was,
can tend to be like,
well,
you know,
we'll make it four times the fucking face value of the ticket.
What,
what do we give a shit if every,
you know,
three out of every four seats is empty almost.
You know,
it wasn't that bad,
but they were big giant swaths of fucking rows that were,
were just,
nobody was there,
um,
from the bottom all the way up to the top.
And I,
you know,
people got flat screen TVs,
they don't need that shit.
They gonna come home,
they'll see the fucking replay.
They'll know the pitch count,
they'll,
you know,
all that shit rather than,
than being like me trying to figure it out.
The scoreboard with my fucked up eyes at this point.
MMM,
okay.
So anyways,
my buddy,
you know,
he's having a few beers and then when he was finished and we just setting them
in the row behind,
he said it was like basically empty.
So there was a guy behind there and you know,
all he had to say was,
hey guys,
do you mind just keeping your empties on you in your role?
Just because,
uh,
you know,
me and the kid and the kid won't try to get by here and oh sorry,
do it.
No problem.
That's how would have gone down.
But instead,
cause he's a west coast guy,
you know,
they still fucking laid back out here.
He immediately just says to my buddy,
good,
this is how we entered the conversation.
He goes,
he's like,
hey buddy,
is there something wrong with the underneath the chair?
Oh,
I'm Fred.
Turns around,
looks at him immediate with that look on his face.
Like,
wow,
I'm about ready to get into a fight.
And he's like,
what?
He goes,
there's something wrong with the underneath part of your chair.
And he's like,
no.
He goes,
why don't you put,
she empties there?
And he goes,
oh,
well there was nobody sitting there.
And then it fucking in,
in like literally like fucking flash paper escalates to this level.
So I'm sitting there,
so I just go,
you know,
okay,
I've been out here long enough.
I'm a veteran.
Like I know this is going to happen.
Okay.
Like you could literally go to the game fucking dressed like Jesus are Santa
Claus.
Whatever the fuck you're into.
And still somebody is going to be like,
you know,
hey,
fuck it.
Uh,
hey whitey.
Okay.
You think you cannot have your fucking beard blowing over your shoulder block
and a half to fucking feel like something's going to happen?
A Santa is,
you still read?
What are you a fucking cardinals fan?
You know,
and all of a sudden you're into it.
So I just turned around and looked at both of them.
I just go,
ladies,
ladies.
What's usually diffuses it?
Somebody saying,
ladies,
all right,
then you realize I got,
alright,
I'm acting like I got it fucking Tampon on,
right?
I go,
we're at the world series game for how?
Come on,
let's have a good time,
right?
So I got to shake the guy's hand behind me and he leaves me hanging.
Okay,
so now I'm fucking mad.
I don't say anything to the guy.
And then I just got just fucking sit out.
So we sit down and then I for for fucking hitting and loudly talking about what
level of fucking asshole fans,
fucking asshole fans that are out here on the fucking west coast.
It's just like they go to the game to get into a fight.
It's just like,
so after eating half of that,
I'm like,
dude,
do you really want to keep doing this?
And it's like,
no I don't.
So I get up,
I go down and get a beer and I'm coming back and I'm going some walking up the
aisle,
this fucking guy,
okay,
it's sitting mean mugging me.
Now this
guy,
he's gotta be like fucking 50 pounds over.
Fucking wait,
there's four of us.
There's one of him.
Now,
granted he's in the row behind us.
I guess maybe he could fall on us and do some fucking damage,
but if we wanted to,
we all probably could have picked him up and thrown him up.
We were the second to last row,
literally just thrown him off the back of the fucking stadium.
All right.
And when you're dealing with people from Boston,
that is,
uh,
there's a chance that there's that level of fucking anger involved.
It wasn't us,
but I'm just saying this guy could give a fuck.
So fucking staring at me as I'm walking up,
he's with his wife and kid and he's fucking staring at us like,
like fucking William Wallace staring at me,
I should say,
as I'm coming up.
So I'm literally,
my eyes are fucking bad at this point,
so I'm like,
is this guy staring at me?
So when you're fucking old,
you gotta either squint or you kind of look away and then look at,
look back at something.
So I had to look away to focus on something else,
and then I looked back at him.
I'm like,
yeah,
he is staring at me and I just looked away.
So he probably thought that was a moment of weakness.
So now he's probably air.
It is.
He's going extra hard with his face now.
I swear to God.
So it just got updated.
I don't know what happened.
All of the anger,
all his shit,
it just went away.
I was just like,
buddy,
we really going to do this man.
Come on.
I respect the Dodgers.
Ever respect you.
We want to try and I apologize for that stuff.
So I got a facility,
I see his face finally relax.
I go to fist bump.
The Guy,
he's so fucking macho,
he can't even like stick his hand and he makes the fist,
but he has his hands still there.
His body.
It's like my daughter when I,
when I first like was like teaching her how to wave and she wouldn't like lift
her hand her arm up.
She would just like open and close your hand while it just rested on a leg.
It was like adorable.
But with this guy it was just so,
I don't know what it was.
It was just like,
wow,
this guy's got a lot of pain.
I don't know what the fuck happened to say.
Fist bump,
long story short
by the end of the game,
even though his Dodgers or lose it.
We're like friends,
we're friendly anyways,
diffused the whole fucking thing and my anger,
my angry fucking Italian Boston guy and what?
He's like,
dude,
how the fuck did you do that?
How to find,
I just said to him,
I was just like,
do it.
I go,
I'm,
I'm fucking done with it.
Um,
I'm,
I'm not,
I'm not fucking doing this anymore.
I'm not going to fucking go to a fucking baseball game.
And then almost getting as a 50 year old bald fucking dude
almost get into a fight
over an empty fucking bud lite beer can and where it was placed within this
concrete structure.
I'm just,
I'm just not,
I'm not fucking doing it any more.
Right.
Iron.
I already almost gotten into a fight with my wife and I diffuse that because we
had pregame at my house and evidently my wife didn't feel like she was invited.
I don't know why we were in the house.
She's always been invited.
But what Ha,
you know what happened?
I came off the road and I was under the gun where I didn't have a lot of time
between getting back to the house,
given her a hug and a kiss,
checking in with my kid and then making sure I had beer for people coming over
to go to the game because the game starts at five and I didn't get back from
Phoenix until,
uh,
you know,
one o'clock didn't get home til like two.
Right.
So,
you know,
they're coming home,
they're coming back.
I'm sorry,
I got home,
I be like one,
one o'clock and my friends were coming over it too.
So I,
I barely hugged and kissed my wife and then asked her to go out and uh,
and get some beer for the guys,
you know,
which is something I never do.
I usually handle everything.
You know,
she's always got the honey do lists for me,
but I never had anything for her.
So I can you get some beers?
And she's looking at me like,
I just asked her if she could fucking walk on water or something.
So a half hour goes by and I'm looking at my,
are you going to go out and get the beer?
And she goes,
are you serious?
I didn't know you were being serious.
And I was like,
yeah,
I'm being serious.
Like why,
why would I say that as a joke?
And she goes,
well cause you know,
I'm,
I'm just sorta sitting here,
you know,
hanging out and you know,
it's one,
it's one of those,
you know,
it's just one of those things in our relationship where it like one person is
going to ask somebody else to do something that they never do themselves or,
or,
or vice versa or something like that.
So I don't know.
She couldn't get her fucking head around it.
So then she goes and she gets the beer,
you know,
she pulls up and of course when she pulls up,
she's like,
can you come out here and help me bring the beer in?
Cause that's what the fuck,
they can never just fucking do something for.
They still got a draggy and right.
And I miss that text.
So my friends went out and helped her out and then she was fucking pissed at me,
a whatever.
So we're driving to the game and she's like texting me about what a jerk I am.
So I fucking diffuse that.
I go to the fucking game,
I diffuse the fat fuck behind us.
That's all I did the whole fucking day.
Diffuse and shit.
As I watched the red sox then go down,
you know,
four to nothing.
And after that crazy fucking game and game three
where we used our starting,
you know,
gain for pitcher.
I mean what,
what,
what?
I mean how great a game did a,
what's his face Bueller pitch?
I feel like people forgot about that.
With the Dodgers winning,
it was all about that guy hitting the home run.
I apologize.
I've got a kid now.
I don't know anybody's fucking names anymore.
I watched the games while I fucking switch back and forth between the game and
puppy dog pals.
Every time I switched from puppy dog pals back to the game.
My daughter just points at the TV goes,
oh,
oh dog,
dog,
dog.
And I got to
Mike.
Just a second.
Mimi Mau.
It sounds like she's speaking like Chinese is something she's saying.
Minnie mouse.
Mimi Mile,
Mimi Mau,
Mimi Mau.
Um,
anyways,
so
I don't even know who hit the fucking home run.
The whole thing was such a blur.
I've been so goddamn busy.
Somebody hit a fucking Omer and for the red sox to make it three nothing,
I mean four to three,
then we scored another run and then we fucking loaded them up.
And then that whole analytics shit that taking guys out there are doing a good
job.
I don't fucking understand.
I mean analytics when in those situations sometimes I swear to God it's like,
it's like baseball's version of the fucking prevent defense where you're like,
I am sure on paper this fucking makes sense.
But uh,
why I,
you know,
stop watching the fucking pitch count.
What is this guy doing
to the opposite team right now?
Oh,
he's,
he sees,
she's fucking killing them.
Buddies up to 27 pitches and,
and the juxtaposition for tis ball and socket joint out fucking shoulder to his,
his,
his juggler.
We need to take them out during the 28th and a half fucking pitch right there
doing that shit.
So anyways,
we end up coming back.
I think we won that.
We were winning the game like nine to four and then Kimbro comes in,
you know,
you know how he closes the game.
He lets up a column run in a fucking double for,
you know,
I know he's coming off an injury.
God bless the guy.
Whatever.
He scared the fucking shit out of me.
And uh,
we won the game and then it was great.
I got to walk on to the stadium.
I didn't have any problem.
I shook the guy's hand behind me and you,
I know I saw a bunch of people wearing red shit there.
Um,
I guess what I'm not,
I'm just too old to do it.
And my favorite fucking part about going to an opposing team stadium
rooting for the other team is when I'm not wearing my own gear and I go into the
bathroom and I don't have to worry that five guys are going to push me in the
back when I go to take a fucking piss.
You know what I mean?
Cause their teams lose it and the the,
the,
the fucking bathroom with all of that porcelain,
all of that tile and none of that,
none of the fucking security and his urine on the floor.
It's just the fucking worst.
And that's,
that's where it goes down.
And to just be able to walk in there and just not have a fucking problem.
I wasn't being a dick when the red sox were scoring runs.
I was definitely chairman,
but I did it in a respectful way.
I didn't do that shit.
I always see that.
And when I'm watching games,
you know,
any game,
any game I watch and I'll see the opposing team's score.
When they cut to the crowd,
you'll always see one douchebag,
not only standing up wearing fucking everything he could possibly be wearing for
the other team.
He's turning around facing the crowd,
you know,
like he's fucking,
Steven Seagal and marked for death and he's going to beat up a whole fucking
section though,
is some fucking fat,
bloated drunk jackass.
And every time I see it,
I always just think like somebody should beat the fuck out of that guy.
Somebody shouldn't,
but you know,
okay.
You never watch the discovery channel,
you don't know how nature works.
Like what?
Yeah,
just no fucking
okay.
I Dunno what,
no.
Uh,
no respect for like your own wellbeing.
Like the fuck,
why the fuck would you do that?
So anyways,
that's just not how I did it.
So then I got home and it was late at night and we would just sit in there like,
can you fucking believe this shit?
It was like we were down four to nothing.
I wasn't even nervous cause I was thinking even if the Dodgers tied the series
up was still going to win it.
Like that's how much a psychology,
and I'm talking about the fucking Boston red sox.
I never thought I would have this feeling about it,
but I just knew these guys were gonna come back.
I didn't think it was going to happen in that game.
And we won that game and I just couldn't fucking believe it.
And I didn't talk one ounce of fucking shit.
None of that stuff.
I just,
you know,
I wanted my team to win.
They won.
That was good enough for me.
I don't need to fucking start walking around being a cunt about it,
but like that's really,
um,
it just really is just sort of sparked part of the,
uh,
sports culture.
And what's funny is,
is how people don't see that their own fans of their team do it too.
Like I know when the red sox were playing New York,
New York for whatever stupid fucking reason in the locker room after we won it,
it was all these Yankee fans
go real close.
You could tell you this with the yogis would listing,
we'll be doing is thinking about the red sox.
It's like,
yeah,
you will be.
Yes she will be because you took the time to go on Twitter to fucking comment on
that.
You took the time to find out about it.
You're obviously on the in in the red sox threads to see it,
you know,
and then they all real classy Boston like and just like,
hey,
you're really forgetting that your fan base through a bear in the face of our
reliever is he came out of the bullpen,
you're going to forget your chanted 1918 at fucking old ladies.
If they had a red sox hat on for the better part of a fucking century may come
on,
grow the fuck up.
It's not something I would do.
I think it's dumb to do that cause it just,
uh,
you know,
gives the other team more incentive or whatever.
But,
uh,
personally speaking,
um,
all I give a shit about is my team.
And like now I'm out of,
the big thing is I would love to see the red sox winning again.
So then we would be in double digits in,
in Champions Championships in two different professional sports,
basketball and um,
and a and baseball.
And I think we would be the first city that ever did that.
Um,
not to mention,
here's another stat if you into fucking stats.
I also believe that the red sox or the first professional sports franchise to
win a championship the same year in two different centuries.
Huh?
Am I going fucking Billy Ball on your hair,
a little nerd enough for you.
Um,
and lastly,
but not leastly I can't remember cause I had to start this podcast again cause
my record record,
it was filled up.
If I did and I don't give a shit,
I'll apologize.
So again,
my apologies to David Price.
Jesus Christ
not have been more wrong and there's going to be a bunch of people out there
being like,
dude,
I fucking sad and I know what,
I never doubted that guy above.
They are full of Shit.
You're full.
I'm maybe not,
but I did.
I 100% thought I actually thought we weren't going to win it and the problem was
going to be that David Price was a headcase,
couldn't beat the Yankees,
couldn't win the big game,
couldn't win fucking October.
I 100% thought that.
Um,
and I was like,
you know,
you need the one two punch,
you need,
you know,
you need to monster shut it down.
Pitchers to win a seven game series.
Now that's how it is with all the free agents seemingly piling on six different
teams and I was 100% wrong.
I actually thought,
you know,
price should have been the MVP considering all of that fucking chatter that was
in his ear and considering,
you know,
he won both his starts,
he came in during the pitch relief and eat up some meetings and he just,
he just crushed it and uh,
couldn't be more happy for that guy and couldn't be more happy that I was 100%
wrong,
100% wrong.
And I loved his,
when he is his press conference afterwards,
when he was going,
you know,
you guys had that card on me and you played it,
you played it well,
but you don't have it anymore.
He goes,
I have the Trump card and it feels great.
And I just pushed one of those sports writers in there,
you know,
they never fucking own up when they're fucking wrong,
or at least not enough.
They should,
one of them should have been like,
Hey David,
how feel,
how good does it feel to stare at all of us who fucking doubted you and wrote
all that bad shit about you,
myself included.
You know,
why don't they ever say that?
You know?
So anyways,
um,
I dunno,
but getting back to that stuff,
I would not have played New York,
New York.
I would not like,
why would you do that?
You,
you fucking kicked the Yankees ass.
You know,
you've got to be above that shit.
But I guess there's always that stuff.
You go to a rangers game and the range is still chant.
Pod Sucks.
I go to an avalanche game,
but at,
at,
at dead dead red wig suck.
You just have your fucking rival.
Um,
and I guess I understand it because Yankee fans were such con for so Goddamn
Long.
Um,
I guess they understand it,
but,
uh,
I'm always,
I always think it's way better to score the touchdown and just hand the ball to
the ref.
You do some stupid dance.
All it does is fucking make the guy covering you.
I don't know,
just want to fucking play that much harder if you just do it like it wasn't
shit.
I just feel like it's just way more defeating.
But what do I know?
You know,
moves last time bill,
you play the game and fucking gym class.
I'm trying to think.
The last time I played other than hockey and played hockey in three years,
so I hurt my back and then I had a kid,
so I,
my hockey stuff has just been sitting there every time I walked by,
I was like,
I have not,
I remember September of 2015 I haven't skated in three fucking years.
Pathetic.
Um,
but anyways,
uh,
so congratulations to the red sox.
Congratulations to the Dodgers,
man.
I know it fucking brutal,
but uh,
it will be all the more sweeter when you finally,
uh,
pushed through and um,
you know,
getting past all this fan shit like I really do.
Like all of those organizations that we played,
including the fucking Yankees mean you can't get mad at the most successful.
You know,
you can't be a fan of sports in that respect.
What the fuck they'd done a and it with that.
That's it.
I'm done talking about it.
The Patriots got the bills tonight.
Hey,
did Lewis Hamilton wrap it up yesterday?
Danny,
I imagine he fucking,
he's always on the podium.
I think all he needed to do is just get into like fourth or fifth place and he
would have had it wrapped up.
Let's see.
Louis Hamilton.
Oh,
by the way,
thank you to everybody that came out to,
um,
okay.
Why does it always go?
How come it always goes to Wikipedia?
Is that because I always go to Wikipedia?
What did I already be up there when 71 is it,
does it die?
Whereas championships,
Yup.
He just wanted 2018 he wanted again.
Congratulations.
Um,
so Lewis Hamilton,
when's the f one championship and Mark Mark Perez one the a moto GP race.
And I want to thank everybody that has helped me along as I've gotten into both
of those sports and I'm absolutely obsessed with them.
Although I've,
you know,
like I said with the Kiddo,
I don't have as much time
mmm.
To watch them the way I want to,
but they are on my DVR.
Um,
what was,
it was in Brazil.
I was Mexico.
That's one of my favorite races where they drive to the old baseball stadium.
MMM.
I am called to that one next year.
Who knows?
All I know is it's Halloween this weekend I'm in town and uh,
we're having this little kid Halloween party,
you know,
you know nightclubs,
so like,
you know,
21 and older.
I think this is like,
it's like 18 months and under.
So it was going to be a bunch of little kids running around.
It's going to be hilarious.
My wife is like totally decked out the house and everything.
Oh,
by the way,
when I came home after the game,
she was still upset with me and I didn't know that she was still up.
So we were outside.
Yeah.
Smoking cigars and shit.
And she texted me,
she's like,
where are you?
I'm like,
I'm downstairs it back porch.
And she got all fucking mad at me.
Like she wasn't invited.
So I went upstairs and I got tight.
She was so trying to have a fight with me.
I just wouldn't have a fight.
It was like,
listen,
I don't want to fight with you.
Just tell me what the problem is.
I love you.
You're awesome.
You love me.
We're not going anywhere.
I don't want to go to bed angry at you.
What did I do that upset you?
And like,
how can we,
how can we work this out and just,
you know,
stop yelling at each other.
I don't want to yell at you.
Yeah.
She says,
okay.
She had to go through that.
You know,
for one,
she was being the baby.
You know,
so that's my new thing.
I'm just,
I don't know what happened somewhere.
That dodger game,
I want to thank that guy who was standing mind me.
The absurdity of it.
It just finally hit me.
It's just like I'm not fucking doing it.
I'm just not doing this anymore.
Jesus Christ.
I just saw a fucking letter for this week.
I'm copying and pasting it right now.
It just said girlfriend wants to bang my brother now that,
that,
that just,
I refuse to believe that that's a true thing.
Whatever.
I'll read that in a minute here.
I got to do the advertising was probably not a good thing to tease right before
I'm going to read advertising,
uh,
advertisements.
Um,
all right.
What the hell is it?
Oh in don't cheat.
Oh,
uh,
talk about stressful.
Talk about,
she'd say how stressful it is knowing you have to go to an event in his suit
that doesn't fit.
Oh yeah.
That's the worst I had to go to.
The reason why I didn't see any a game are clinching red sox game yet.
Cause I had to go to a wedding and we had the after the after party for season
three of 'em F is for family.
We had a great time.
We actually went bowling and a,
so I kind of do like double duty last night.
So I was watching that whole thing on my phone.
Um,
but anyways,
I love going to weddings now.
Now that I'm married and I have a kid,
it's like all the pressures over I did it.
Okay.
I committed to somebody I procreated,
you know,
fuck off.
I imagine it's the same feeling David Price has right now.
Okay,
I did it.
I got a ring.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I am the David Price of wedding wedding guests right now.
Um,
anyways,
what it was Indochino right Indochino here's how it works.
Visit a
stylist@ourshowroomandhavethemtakeyourmeasurementspersonallyormeasureathomeyourselfandshoponlineatindochino.com
choose your fabric inside and out.
Choose your design customization.
Submit your measurements with your choices,
relaxed while you suit,
gets professionally tailored and mailed to you in a couple of weeks.
Call to action.
This is mandatory Ra.
This week.
My listeners can get any premium Indochino suit for just 359
dollars@indochino.com when entering burr at checkout,
that's 50% off the regular price for a made to measure premium suit plus
shipping is free.
That's indochino.com promo code birth for any premium suit for just $359 and
free shipping and credible deal for a premium made to measure suit.
Indochino are also expanding into casual clothing you're made to measure.
Chinos will quickly become your goto pant pairing as easily with suit jackets as
they do with a sweater and there'll be good,
oh my God,
they go with a fucking suit jacket and a sweater.
That's totally my wheel house right now.
That's the age group Omid Start Wearing sport coats on fucking a stage of at
that age,
you know,
cover up my fucking the mistakes.
I've made it the fucking kitchen counter.
All right,
Ziprecruiter,
that's actually not true.
I'm actually in good shape right now,
but you know,
it's always good to have a big sport coat hanging around for one year.
You're going through your fat months,
you know the holidays.
Anyway,
Ziprecruiter,
you know what's not smart job sites that overwhelm you with tons of the wrong
resumes.
But do you know what is smart zip recruiter.com/bar unlike other jobs sites,
ZipRecruiter doesn't wait for candidates to find you all zip
Vic marrow finds them for you.
It's powerful.
Matching technology scans thousands of resumes,
identifies people with the right skills,
education,
and experience for your job and activity.
Actively.
Sorry,
invites them to apply so you get qualified candidates fast.
No more sorting through the wrong resumes.
No more waiting for the right candidates to apply.
It's no wonder that Ziprecruiter isn't is rated number one by employers in the
US.
Um,
this rating comes from hiring sites on trust pilot with over 1000 reviews.
Okay,
leave them.
They're backing it up.
A little footnotes there and right now my listeners can try zip,
okay.
For Free at the exclusive web address,
ziprecruiter.com/bird that's ziprecruiter.com/bar hey,
sip
[inaudible] dot com slash burns CIP,
r,
e c r u,
I t e r.com.
The smartest way to hire.
Oh,
look who's here.
What do we got?
Three more.
Let's break this up.
Let's read some fucking,
let's read some fucking questions here.
Let's read some questions here and then when I get off this thing,
yeah,
I got to go do that.
The honey,
the honey do list,
right?
And you know what?
I'm going to do it with everybody.
I would do it with the fucking smile on my face and I'm not,
I'm not going to,
uh,
yeah,
I'm done dude.
I am.
I'm done fighting.
I've had it.
I'm so,
he keeps saying it out loud.
So I make it a real thing.
I'm done with it.
What is the fucking problem?
What I really need to say?
I'm sorry.
What is the problem?
But I,
I,
the only place I've graduated to right now is what is the fucking problem.
All right,
if I can take the fuck out of there,
get some of the angry tone out of my voice,
I think I'll be doing even better.
All right,
granted,
I'll probably run out of material,
but that's beside the point.
Speaking of material,
if you guys here to Patriot Patriot on announcement here,
why?
Uh,
by popular demand,
people have been asking for more constant content where they can donate,
et cetera.
Um,
all right.
The why,
what,
and all of this shit.
All right.
I have a new,
I'm going to have a,
I'm launching a Patrion page.
Okay.
It's going to go live on November 5th.
All right.
Yeah.
Um,
and this is what you're going to get all this extra content.
All right.
Spelled P a.
You're going to get two episodes of the uninformed podcasts with me and old Joey
roses.
I'm bringing it back.
You get extra video content city.
Oh,
tour city tours.
Backstage footage.
Okay.
Helicopter Rides.
Whatever the fuck I'm doing.
How much is it?
It's five bucks a month.
Jesus Christ.
Lay off on a couple of fucking cards,
their eggs and you and you got yourself all this other content.
All right.
November's content.
We'll go live November 5th.
I have a,
I videoed a podcast.
It's a live podcast from Phoenix.
That was a good podcast to full video of the show as well as downloads to MP,
three,
two episodes of uninformed and um,
I'm going to be doing a bunch of other fucking,
you know,
Paisano behind the scenes shit at my shows and all that of stuff.
Um,
you know,
it's funny they say don't you have a patriotic page and they don't even tell me.
I guess you go to Patrion and you'd just try to look up my name,
whatever.
I'll keep promoting,
I'll promote it.
And again,
speaking of which,
uh,
please watch on a,
what is it this week,
November 3rd,
Paul Versey standup special,
uh,
on comedy central is coming out and it was done by my,
my company that I started with Al Madrigal,
all things comedy.
This is our first special that is coming out.
We're very excited and it would be you,
it would be huge this Thursday night if you guys could.
Uh,
is that what it is?
Not on,
on.
I sat Thursday night looking at the wrong thing.
Sunday night,
Sunday,
Wah Wah Wah Wah Wah Wah.
No,
that's the wrong one too.
Why is it in May?
I swear to God,
don't,
don't even listen to me.
Here we go.
I'm sorry.
This Saturday night,
November 3rd,
Paul versus stand up special on comedy central.
I think it comes on at midnight.
Um,
okay.
Yeah,
I'm just really proud of them.
This is just one of these guys who should have got a special a long time ago and
did not end with the company that I started with.
Al Madrigal add matter with Myalgia.
Go being the driving force behind it.
We're able to get ourselves in position.
We actually made a deal with comedy central and we're producing,
um,
for one hour specials for them for the next year.
This is the first one.
And we're going to be picking all these comics that we love and I'm so please
check that out if you can.
All right,
let's,
let's read.
Let's read a little less questionnaire.
Corvette.
Hey Billy Bean ball bag.
Uh,
need advice on a car I would love to purchase next year.
I'm looking to try a,
trying to get a c seven corvette.
The latest model Corvettes.
A C seven.
Okay.
Or is that the bar?
Is that the body type?
Oh,
what do you do?
You know,
look at that.
I can't fucking hear myself.
What just happened?
Gravity happened.
Nah,
I got to sit there and literally hold this thing.
I literally have my thumb down on the connection here.
Like one of those bad action movies where the guy comes walking and go on a
bike,
take my thumb off,
is paid.
We all go up.
I got to do that for the rest of the podcast.
Evidently.
Um,
so anyways,
so I imagine that's fucking shit.
Jesus fucking Christ.
They'll go to a radio shack and just by what the fuck he need said at dealing
with this every week.
Fucking moron.
Hey,
you know what?
I'm also done getting mad at inanimate objects.
Children.
Rosa had a great bit about that.
And I remember listening to it going,
you know what?
I really should learn how to do that.
And I haven't.
And as far as I can tell,
he hasn't learned how to not do it either.
Anyways,
uh,
it's the latest model.
Corvettes.
I'm currently 23 years old,
married to an absolute fucking gem,
have a house with her and pay for everything we want.
Slash half.
Dude,
you're fucking killing it.
Uh,
not trying to pat myself on the back,
but I'm happy with where I am in life anyways.
Do you think it would be good or dumb idea to get a corvette next year and I'm
going to be a little bitch and get an automatic.
I want to be able to have my mom drive it since that's her dream car.
Otherwise I would just get a manual anyways.
Don't go fuck yourself and keep on keeping on.
Um,
dude,
if you know you're married to a gem and you're living within your means,
if you can afford to get a corvette,
get a corvette,
you know,
here's the deal.
I don't know if they make it in a stick still.
It seems like everything is just the paddle shifting.
Um,
if you still can get it into stick and he'd be a great way to teach your mom how
to drive a stick.
She grinds the gears on your brand new corvette.
Probably a dumb idea.
Sounded good in my head until I fucking said that.
Um,
although I tell you one of the big things then in the future that I want to do
with my daughters,
I want to teach her how to drive my truck,
which is three on the column.
And um,
I think,
yeah,
how bad ass will that be?
That she,
you know,
that someone born in 2017 we'll know how to drive a 1968 Ford f 100 and she's a
lady.
Yeah.
My Kid's going to be a bad ass.
She's going to know how to do shit.
She's not gonna be when these fucking pretty girl sitting at the bar link.
I'm just going to pretend I don't know things.
Um,
anyways.
Yeah,
I think that's a great idea.
If you want to get,
you know,
if,
she,
she seems like he kind of also doing it for your mom,
which is a great thing.
Um,
man cars,
you know,
I dunno when people are like car people,
it really means a lot when they,
they get the one that they've always wanted.
Um,
you know,
I dunno,
I have bought,
I bought a car,
you know,
I bought the car my wife wanted and I saw the look on her face so I can imagine,
and that's the woman that I'm married,
so I know what that feeling's life.
I can't imagine if you get it for your mom in,
you're able to pay her back like that.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I would fucking do that.
Um,
why don't you go buy a shit box in the meantime,
that's a stick and go teach your mom how to drive,
drive,
drive a standard transmission.
Be Great together time.
You'll laugh your asses off and uh,
you know,
and that's great for how somebody who's older to learn something new.
It's a lot of options here,
man.
Men are all good.
Glad you're life is in that place at that email actually made,
made me happy.
Believe it or not,
somebody killing it like that.
See that I got a good hat.
All right,
girlfriend wants to bang my brother.
Ah,
we,
I teased this earlier in the podcast.
Girlfriend wants to Bang
my brother,
Jesus Christ.
I would love to hear Joel Olsteen read this fucking thing.
I mean,
Jesus wants your girlfriend or bang your brother.
Uh,
hey bill,
I'm sure this happens.
This has happened to you before.
Is that a long roundabout way of saying that I'm not a good looking guy,
but how should I handle my girlfriend wanting to bang my brother more than me?
Thoughts?
She said it three times in one night.
Okay.
What,
why are you still in this relationship?
Okay.
Would you still be in the relationship if you said that about our says,
hey,
listen sweetheart,
not to say you don't have a nice rack,
but like,
I mean you,
you got to agree with me.
I mean your,
your sister's tits are ridiculous.
Do you know how bad I want to stick my dick between the two of them?
You know what,
what,
what's okay.
You told me to be honest with you.
Um,
um,
anyway,
she said it in one night,
three times in one night and that he is better looking,
et cetera.
So she's either going to fuck him or she's just trying to get under my skin.
I told her after the third time to go fuck him then and she tried to act like I
was an asshole.
Yes,
of course.
Of course she did.
I feel like this cross the line and it's all I can think about.
Okay.
Oh Dude,
I got to tell you something right now.
Not only do you say that you fucking dumper
for her to fucking say that to you is so out of line and that is just the tip of
the fucking iceberg of the mind.
Games a fucking asshole.
Like this is going to play with somebody.
All right,
dump this person and this is the thing she's going to have actually fucking
respects you because she obviously doesn't respect you enough that she's saying
that shit to you.
So if you fucking dumper,
you know what's going to actually make her want to do is fuck you more.
And this is what you do.
This is the jet I level.
You know what?
When she wants to fuck you more after that,
you know what you do yet.
Dot fucker done.
Done.
It's over.
That's one of those things like,
I don't know what kind of a fucking jerk off you think I am like that.
That's basically what she's saying to you there.
She thinks you're a fucking jerk off and you have to show her that you're not.
I would dumper and then that is fucking it.
That is fucking it.
And when she fucking,
um,
does all of those women manipulating things and fucking turns on the sex vibe
and all that dude,
you fucking,
you like nothing.
You give her nothing.
Okay.
That's it.
I don't need to read the rest of this.
I will though.
Um,
if it was a friend of mine,
she thought was more attractive,
I wouldn't care.
You should care.
She shouldn't be saying that,
dude.
This is,
this is why you don't fucking say that.
Let me ask you this.
Could you do any of this to her?
Could you say that one of her,
her girlfriends is more attractive than her three times in one night.
Anyways,
he said,
but I hate the fact it's my baldheaded fuck of a brother.
What should I do?
Anything I think about,
I get more angry.
Uh,
thanks and wear a hat next.
I'm like,
are you taking your anger out on me?
Um,
yeah,
dude.
You're dating somebody that has crossed the line that you're not going to be
able to get past.
Okay.
Pass.
Sorry.
Am I really going to save my voice?
Dude?
I've been screaming and yelling every weekend doing my act and been watching the
red sox through the playoffs.
So I apologize for my son.
I'm going through puberty here.
Oh yeah.
Dude,
that is a no fucking brainer,
you know?
Uh,
just dumper and it's another thing.
Don't tell your older brother or younger brother,
whoever your brother is.
Don't,
don't tell your brother why you dumped it.
Because one day he's going to get drunk.
He's going to bring it up and then,
you know,
like an asshole and then you guys are gonna get to a fight.
Okay?
And it's all because of this,
this cunt who is trying is driving a wedge into your family.
This is,
this is the kind of person you're going to bring this person into the a family
trait.
Uh Huh.
You're going to dump your fucking seat into that.
I don't think you are.
Walk away.
And you know what,
Dude,
you got off fucking easy.
If you dumped this woman right now,
Jesus Christ.
God bless the poor fucking bastard that she's going to fucking marry right
there.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
deer hill,
Billy Buck tooth.
Uh,
I'm in a bit of a pickle.
I'm 23 letters,
lot of,
lot of emails from 23 year olds this week.
Evidently a 23 year olds.
I haven't have a,
a little difficult fucking time here.
Um,
deer hill,
Billy Buck tooth,
uh,
um,
a bit of an m and a bit of a pickle.
I'm 23 and want to break up with my girlfriend of two years.
We're long distance.
I'm a kiwi.
She's a Yank.
Oh,
what's a Kiwi again?
Is that fucking New Zealand?
I can't,
I can't even keep up.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
now I gotta look it up.
I don't want you guys to sound ignorant like me.
Here we go.
Key we p Bowl Wikipedia.
Once again,
Kiwi is a nickname used for international internationally for people from New
Zealand,
as well as being relatively common.
Self-Reference unlike many demograph flavor,
its uses is not considered offensive,
rather,
it's generally viewed as a symbol of pride and an endearment from,
for the people of New Zealand.
The name derives from the Kiwi,
a native flightless bird,
which is a national symbol of New Zealand.
It's a flightless bird,
man.
He,
you guys aren't leaving the island.
Is that what it is?
Until the first world war,
the Kiwi representative the country and not the people.
However,
by 1917,
New Zealanders were being called Kiwis supplanting other nicknames.
Well that's cool.
It's great that eventually it didn't become offensive.
Usually after a while it does.
Are you saying that my dreams will never take flight?
Ooh.
Um,
anyways.
Uh,
I'm a kiwi.
Eat,
she's a yank.
Uh,
sure.
Blocker on Facebook.
Okay.
I'm 23 and want to break up with my girlfriend at two years.
Okay,
well you just sit down.
He just say,
listen,
we have to talk.
All right.
This is something that I wish somebody just told me.
This is what you say,
you just sit down to see,
honey,
listen,
we have to talk.
Is something wrong?
And then you just say,
yes,
I'm just,
I'm not happy.
Okay.
I don't think you're a bad person or anything,
but I'm just,
okay,
this just doesn't feel right.
You know,
it feels right in that I like you,
but it doesn't feel like I like you to the point that I'm going to marry you.
And then they just stopped talking and said,
and then she'll start fucking crying and blah,
blah,
blah.
And she's crying because she's sad.
And that is a normal emotion and you have to be comfortable with that.
And just you,
you just said it.
No.
Did you say?
Yeah,
no.
And I,
I,
I think we need to,
uh,
end this relationship now,
I think,
and we need to end this relationship.
That's it.
He said it,
I'm not happy.
I'm not feeling like you're the person I'm going to marry.
We need to end this relationship.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
We need to talk.
I'm not happy.
Yeah,
you just fucking,
that's it.
And you just get it all out.
And it's going to be another two fucking hours,
but you don't waver.
You don't go back and then,
then you're out.
That's it.
And then you go back.
Anyways,
he says,
sure.
Blocker on block her on Facebook and other social medias.
We used to correspond.
The problem is she has a lot of filthy nudes of mine.
I've sent her over the past few years.
Needless to say,
I have my fair share of hers.
All right,
well that's a stalemate then.
I'm worried she'll distribute them maliciously and revenge for breaking it off
with her.
She's that kind of spiteful.
Trust me.
Any advice other than hindsight,
thanks and go fuck yourself.
You can just going to have to man up and do it,
dude.
You know?
And if the world's going to see a dick for a couple of days,
then so be it.
That's it.
All right.
And um,
I'm actually happy for you because who wants to be,
who would want to marry a spiteful person
because she,
she would have done that to you if you stayed with their in other areas.
You're not happy.
Get the fuck out of it.
And then your hindsight stop sending Dick Pics to people,
you know.
Okay.
I Dunno.
That's,
that's how I lead that way.
What do you have a fucking lay in there?
Like Burt Reynolds in playgirl?
Cause if you weren't covering your junk,
I don't understand.
Like I understand women cause they're beautiful.
I just don't understand.
I don't understand.
Understand guys doing that.
Uh,
you like these dick and balls hanging off here.
Um,
a naked guy.
It's like literally it looks like it's like a design flaw.
You know,
women are all curvy.
It's smooth and aerodynamic,
you know,
other went to the point,
other women can look at other naked women and be like,
oh my God,
she's beautiful.
You know what I mean?
A naked guy,
you know.
Ah,
it's Craig,
you're fucking this shit hanging off.
Cover it up.
Um,
dilemma a,
hey bill,
I'm writing in as another female listener going on six years now.
Love your work and I'm hoping you can help me decide something.
I right.
I love when the ladies right in.
I'm 18,
just turned 18.
All right.
She's legal.
Uh,
and I've been working at an estate firm for three years.
Look at you.
Good for you.
I even know what that is,
but that sounds impressive to me.
Um,
I'm a sophomore in college.
How are you only 18 years old doing all this stuff?
You're like advanced classes.
Most people who could play the cello when you were three.
Uh,
I'm on a sophomore.
I'm a sophomore in college pursuing a criminal degree.
Then going on to law school.
I've always wanted to be a criminal defense attorney.
Well,
let's say you're going to make that happen by the time you're like 21.
Anyways.
However,
the lady I work for who runs the estate from once,
yeah,
to pass the firm to me,
but I never intended to pursue a career in a state law by dilemmas seems to be,
I can't decide whether I should accept this overwhelmingly kind offer of the
estate from ready for me when I graduate law school or start from scratch at the
bottom and criminal law.
The estate firm would need some work.
But all in all is a business.
From listening to your story of how you are a self made man.
I would assume you would say pick criminal if that's what you've always wanted.
But who in their right mind turns down a firm that's wrapped and ready with
their name on it?
Looking forward to your insight.
Uh,
you make rush hour drives bearable.
Thanks.
And kindly go fuck yourself from another broad.
Alright.
Jesus Christ,
is this like the coolest person ever.
She's 18.
She's crushing it.
Um,
listen,
okay.
You're an amazingly successful person for 18 years of age and I would look at it
like this,
the state from,
it's just,
you know,
it's like when Columbus was sailing across the ocean before he saw land,
it was a couple of tree branches.
So that's what's coming here.
You seeing that your,
your big things come and you can definitely go do what the fuck you want to do.
Um,
I think you'll regret way more.
Yeah.
Not trying to be in the part of law that you wanted to be,
and then walking away from some money because,
uh,
you know,
the money,
the money makes money,
makes you like relaxed as far as like,
he can pay your bills and shit like that,
but it doesn't do anything for,
for like your soul or your heart.
You know what I mean?
Your passions,
it just doesn't,
unless your passion is you love fucking money,
um,
you know,
whatever the fuck that is.
Uh,
so yeah,
I would definitely just stay on the track that you're on.
Okay.
And you know,
just tell the person,
I am obviously ridiculously flattered,
but you know,
my dream since I've been little has been to be a criminal defense attorney.
That's the direction that's the part of law I want to be in.
And I just know that I would have this regret while I ran your state from,
and your state from deserves somebody that has the same level of passion for a
state law is I do for criminal law.
And there you said it and the person is going to sit down.
They're going to start crying.
No kidding.
You know,
it's like really like this should be a course on how to break up with somebody
and then also how to have confrontations like this anywhere from the fat guy yet
yet behind you at a baseball game to somebody offering you something that nobody
would say no to,
but your,
your heart is saying,
I can't do this.
Um,
okay.
And that's it.
And the thing about it is,
is what you have to learn as a young person is you have to learn that this,
this is one of the biggest,
biggest skills in life is learning how to have,
um,
productive confrontation.
Okay.
All right.
Where you express what you want and you get what you want.
Or at the very least you stated what you want.
If you're not getting what you want,
you walk,
but you don't do it.
There's no name calling.
There's no raising of voices.
And even if the other person goes there,
you don't match their energy.
You just let them yell and stuff like that and you just comp,
um,
they,
they should,
I don't know.
I'm sure somebody is doing that out there,
but they just don't do it enough.
And um,
you know,
I turned a corner the other night with my wife where I,
I didn't go to where our energy was.
I understood why she was upset with me and I told her she was right.
You are right.
I didn't come home and ask you how you were doing.
You're right.
I apologize for that.
I work on that.
But like I don't want to yell at you.
I love you.
That's it.
I mean,
what the fuck is someone going to do with that Kevin,
yet that you love me then?
And he just,
he just sounds stupid.
And women,
fortunately enough or rational enough that you can kind of talk,
come down,
you know,
we're guys,
like I don't want to deal with my emotions.
You don't,
you just go for a fucking butterfly,
new thing.
Then I go,
okay,
go for a walk.
You know,
I go for a walk,
I go out to my garage,
I played drums,
couple of Pantera songs,
and I've just lost myself in that.
And then I come back and I can just sit,
you know,
it's a little weird that someone in the middle of a fucking discussion has to go
on and go play to some van Halen and then come back before they can be.
But you know,
I,
you know,
I have some growing up to do,
but whatever.
Um,
so that,
yeah,
that's what I would do.
And you know,
I eat,
if you do an all of this already,
like this is not going to be the last opportunity.
And how much better would it be if you built your own firm?
You know,
I think that'd be pretty bad ass.
All right.
But do whatever you want to do.
But that,
that's my,
that's my feeling.
Sorry,
withdrawals.
I been listening to the podcast since the first episode.
This is my third day off of opiates.
Congratulations.
Uh,
I've been on pain manage a pain management scheduled for the last five years due
to arthritis in my spine.
MMM.
Eating painkiller after painkiller for the last five years.
Eventually I got to the point where I was starting to question if I was addicted
or not.
Every time I took a pain killer,
he kind of skipped a few words there,
but you're going through withdrawals.
The fact that you actually able to sit down and fucking write an email and it
was a victory in itself.
Asking myself if I still have it under control.
I'm a single dad with the career.
I work long hours at night and I'm lucky enough to still be there to get my son
from school every day.
Uh,
I've never missed one of his games or races,
but at the same time,
um,
I've been taking these painkillers every day.
It felt like carrying a demon on my back.
I'm only three days into being cleaned still.
We're drawing,
still can't sleep.
Skin is crawling all of the normal symptoms.
That hasn't stopped me from my daily responsibilities out.
Dude,
you're a fucking Troper.
Nobody really knows that I'm growing through this.
I don't open up about things like this to people.
Well,
that that's what you need to do immediately.
He said,
which is why I'm writing you.
I don't want anything in return just to vent to this,
to someone.
I've been relistening to the podcast to pass the time until these withdraws are
over,
there's absolutely no chance that I'll ever go back to painkillers.
I feel miserable right now,
but it's the best feeling I've had felt in a long time.
Good for you.
No more demon on my back.
Well that's great.
Well you need to reach out to people cause it's okay to,
uh,
say that you need help.
And um,
you know,
from what I've heard,
getting off opiates is,
is,
is difficult,
is trying to kick heroin,
which is also an opiate.
Right.
I'm glad.
I don't know a lot about drugs like that,
so,
um,
you know,
I just,
yeah,
definitely let people know what you're going through.
A yeah,
I'll leave it at that.
That's,
that's a heavy fucking subject.
So it's a tough fucking guy,
man.
Jesus skin crawl and he's still doing everything he needs to do for his family
and he's,
um,
I'm not going back.
That's an old school fucking guy,
John Wayne Shit right there.
Um,
anyways.
Oh,
it's the holiday season.
Dooby dooby dough.
Um,
I'm going to be on Jimmy Kimmel tonight promoting the front runner movie
starring Hugh Jackman.
It's the,
uh,
the Gary Halbert story,
directed by Jason Reitman.
I'm so psyched to be in this movie.
A truly is,
you know,
one of the great things I've been able to be a part of as far as being in an
ensemble.
Ah.
Um,
so check that out tonight.
And uh,
other than that,
I got to go buy a shirt to wear on Kimmel cause you know,
God knows you can't wear the same shirt on TV more than once.
I can't do that.
You know,
oh you fucking assholes and make fun of me who have,
you know,
10 shirts that are in there,
that ship your pitching staff,
that's your rotation.
10 fucking shirts yet,
show Biz,
you know,
allowed to do that.
You gotta wear it once.
So what you do is,
I always try to pick something that,
you know,
it doesn't really stand out,
just sort of a bland fucking color.
You get any sort of designs on it.
The people that God had said the shirts you wore fucking camel.
Yeah,
it is now wearing it again once I spoke to throw it out.
You wasteful can't.
Um,
anyway,
so I have to do that and I'm also going to be,
uh,
you know,
I always make pumpkin bread during,
uh,
between um,
what is it,
Halloween and thanksgiving.
Thanksgiving.
I start busting out the pies.
I make my fucking stuffing.
I'm throwing down this year cause I'm gonna be in town.
I can't wait.
I'm very excited and uh,
I think my daughter's still one year away from maybe going trick or treating.
I Dunno.
I'll ask the AF.
I'll have to ask my wife about that.
But that's it.
Go Patriots.
Congratulations to Lewis Hamilton.
Mark Mark has the Boston red sox and um,
yeah,
that's it.
What a great fucking a week for me as a sports fan.
All right.
And I'm not rubbing it in either.
I hope the Dodgers win it again next.
If we don't,
how's that?
That's the nicest thing I could say.
All right.
Okay.
That's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
Enjoy the next couple of days.
Please watch Paul Versey special,
uh,
November 3rd on comedy central,
one of my best friends in the world,
and I'm so proud of him.
He's got a great,
great,
great special that he did with the all things comedy network.
Uh,
I'll check in on,
yeah,
on Thursday.